we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a bit
of a complaint / advice about my
handling of the twenty twenty democratic
primaries so far take a listen to this
yeah i think there's a little too hard
on all the female candidates and i think
you had to give them a little more of a
chance
towards lame guy or whatever but holy
hell it's a year and a half away give
the females a chance by yeah
i think i hear my own voice in the
background there i think she called in
while listening listen my top hand that
it is a woman right now I think if the
election were today I'm either in the
camp of Elizabeth Warren or Andrew yang
I have ruled off of my list Kamala
Harris and Tulsi Gabbard I've given
reasons why none of them have anything
to do with their gender kirsten
gillibrand is still in the running as
far as I'm concerned there are you know
there's there's a bunch of different
candidates here and I am making
evaluations based on policy I've
identified policy reasons why Kamala
Harris and Tulsi Gabbard aren't for me
but again my top person right now is a
woman and that's Elizabeth Warren so I
don't think that bringing I don't I
don't know that the gender angle is the
most useful one for us to evaluate the
lens through which I am choosing and
picking candidates for the 2020
Democratic primary if you disagree let
me know we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will by the way talk about
Elizabeth Warren's tax proposal which is
popular even with most with many
Republicans rather we will talk about
very strange things going on with a
courtroom CCTV system and we will talk
about NASA planning to knock an asteroid
off of its orbit in the first attempt of
its kind all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get access by
becoming a member or a patron I'll speak
to you then
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka Steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
/ Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm / Pakman that's B Li NK
is t.com /pa ke ma n